bonjour à tous la france attaque en
justice apple et google pour pratiques
commerciales abusives et toutes les
entreprises du net pourrait aussi être
poursuivi au niveau européen et ça on va
le regarder le début d'année n'est pas
très très bon pour apple la fin d'année
déjà s'est terminée avec des problèmes
d'obsolescence programmée problèmes qui
ont continué d'éluder mais 18 et cette
fois ci c'est l'état français qui
s'attaque directement à apple et à
google
pourquoi pour des questions de pratiques
commerciales abusives
c'est du moins ce qu'a annoncé le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
bruno le maire sur rtl la france
s'attaque donc au géant du net pour
ramener de la justice pour les
développeurs et pour les start up
française il reproche à apple et à
google les conditions de travail des
développeurs ce soit des tarifs imposées
des contrats qui sont modifier
unilatéralement et la récupération des
données jeu si bruno le maire je
considère que google et apple aussi
puissant soit-il n'ont pas traité nos
startups et nos développeurs de la
manière dont ils le font aujourd'hui
selon ministre et risquerait une
sanction de plusieurs millions d'euros
que tu es toujours a cité bruno le maire
ma responsabilité c'est d'être garant de
l'ordre public économique
il y a des règles et il ya une justice
elle doit être respectée de plus il
assuré continuer à se battre pour que
les géants du numérique que ce soit
google amazon apple payent leurs impôts
en france qui aujourd'hui mais
globalement pas le cas je cite une fois
de plus s'il beaucoup aujourd'hui je ne
vois pas pourquoi une pme père et ses
impôts et par google ou amazon en france
il se bat donc sur deux fronts le
premier c'est effectivement une
problématique plus intérieure à savoir
le traitement fait par google et par
apple au niveau des développeurs et des
start up qui travaille sur les
applications les applications pour
trouve bien sûr sur l'appstore et sur le
plat et stores et de notre côté au
niveau européen pour prendre un peu le
lead prendre la tête d'une action
collective pour tous les géants du net
payent des impôts en france
les gens du net qu'on appelle gaffe à
google amazon facebook apple yahoo
microsoft twitter et j'en passe et des
meilleurs toutes ces entreprises quand
de l'optimisation fiscale pour pas payer
d'impôts en france
ils ont domicilié le pôle européen dans
des pays qui vont vraiment les avantages
et d'un point de vue fiscal est
néanmoins avec l'europe
ils peuvent rayonner sur tout le
territoire européen et tout ça sans
aller payer d'impôts dans chaque pays
européen
si la législation change d
vinette pourrait devoir payer des impôts
dès l'année prochaine en tout cas c'est
ce qu'espère bruno le maire que les
textes soient mis en place en 2018 pour
une application en 2019
ce qui fait que tous les gens du net
devrait s'acquitter d'impôts dans chaque
pays de l'union européenne et ça ça
pourrait faire relativement mal au
portefeuille
d'un autre côté sa part assez normal que
les entreprises qui font un chiffre
d'affaires dans différents pays que ce
soit la france qui met zot l'allemagne
l'espagne le portugal peu importe ça
paraît assez normal puisque qu'ils
engrangent de l'argent de ce côté là
qu'ils doivent effectivement participer
à l'effort collectif à l'impôt après on
va pas rentrer dans un débat politique
c'est pas le but de la chaîne mais en
tout cas ça paraît effectivement assez
normal que sur la partie du chiffre
d'affaires réalisé en france
qu'il y ait des impôts qu'ils soient
payés en france la commission européenne
doit présenter ses propositions pour
instaurer un impôt qui ré l'ours de 2 à
6% du chiffre d'affaires
ça fait des années que les gens du net
sur mon ordinateur pour l'optimisation
fiscale pour l'instant rien n'avait été
fait est ce qu'aujourd'hui pour y avoir
une modification à cause des tensions
qu'il ya avec les états unis de donald
trump
c'est en tout cas une possibilité dit me
d'ailleurs vous ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire bon pour les utilisateurs
assurez vous sait très globalement pas
changé grand chose de toute façon
aujourd'hui les services d'apple et de
google sur les stores sont gratuits par
contre du côté des développeurs et les
tarifs pourrait effectivement être revu
un peu à la hausse c'est effectivement
tout l'intérêt de l'action croisés quand
on trouvait avec l'état français à
vouloir protéger d'un autre côté ces
développeurs et les startups qui
travaillent pour des applications qui
seront mises en ligne sur le playstation
store ce qui est super intéressant de ce
côté là ces combats que l'union
européenne est en train d'essayer de
légiférer pour empêcher les abus liés
aux gaffes à tous ces géants du net qui
profite d'un système fiscal avantageux
et d'un autre côté l'état français qui
essaye vraiment de protéger les startups
les développeurs pour éviter de ne voir
une flambée des prix et que le coût de
l'impôt leur soient répercutées c'est
vrai que c'est une problématique est
très intéressante on n'en parle pas
énormément on va pas non plus attendre
des heures là dessus mais c'est vraiment
intéressant de se rendre compte un petit
peu des coulisses comment font ces
géants du net pourrait y ait toujours
plus d'argent et pour accroître les
marges donc dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous êtes sensible à
ces actions est ce que vous trouvez que
le gouvernement va dans le bon sens en
voulant récupérer de l'impôt par rapport
à l'entreprise
est ce que vous trouvez qu'ils ont
raison de vouloir protéger les
développeurs et les startups marque et
matous sans commentaire bien évidemment
on va rester connecté
s'il ya du nouveau on en reparlera je
vous invite comme d'hab a laissé des
jolies pousse à rester connectés à vous
menée parce qu'on parlait toujours plus
de technologies d'actualité tech de
plein de produits et de plein de choses
hyper cool
restez connectés d'ici là soyez sage je
vous embrasse à bientôt à bientôt
portez vous bien ciao